hey there whitehouse.gov fans bill Mahr
here you know back in January I
celebrated a birthday it was a big one I
was 32 anyway I used the occasion to
make a plea for the president to come on
real time not just because I'm a true
fan but because I thought our large
loyal audience deserved to be treated to
a presidential visit just like other
shows have and because as an audience we
sometimes think a little differently
about things and I know this president
is sincere about extending diversity
everywhere in America the petition we
sent out that night asking the President
to sit down with me we would cover
parking and dress would be business
casual was answered in good faith and
now I'm thrilled the president has as he
did with the country come through in the
end
so we'll see it all here on November 4th